alguna vez se han encontrado con uno de
esos niños insoportables que no obedecen
son distraídos o que parecen faltos de
papado de disciplina
pues es posible que uno de esos niños
tenga tdh saben ustedes que significa
tdh
quizás lo había escuchado pero nunca me
había preocupado por entender de qué se
trataba
th trastorno de déficit de atención e
hiperactividad
llegó a mi vida de la manera menos
esperada y si no hubiera sido por esta
pandemia seguramente nunca me había dado
cuenta que mi hija tiene este trastorno
antes de que llegara la pandemia tenía
una vida normal en la familia conformada
por mi esposo mis dos hijas maría el
maní martina y mi madre que vive con
nosotros no había normal trabajos
colegios actividades extracurriculares
deportes una vida social y así se nos
pasaban los días y las semanas
la cuarentena nos obligó a estar de unas
horas en el día pasar 24/7 compartiendo
en familia
de esta manera la vida empieza a tener
un sentido diferente y comenzamos a
darnos cuenta de cosas que no veíamos de
nuestras hijas maría del mar por ejemplo
comencé a tener comportamientos
agresivos y depresivos que llegué a
escuchar por su probable escencia claro
marjal maría tiene 13 años sin embargo y
aunque en muchos comportamientos
extraños aparecieran tan pronto cumple
los 12 siempre los dejaba pasar por alto
un día maría del mar tuvo una crisis muy
fuerte se comportó agresiva y no era la
primera vez ya era tres veces durante la
pandemia un amigo muy cercano me dijo
que debía buscar ayuda y así decidimos
con mi esposo nos fuimos para urgencias
y maría el malo estuvo ocho días alejada
de nosotros
el acompañamiento permanente de
especialidad de especialistas como
psiquiatras psicólogos conductuales y
otro tipo de psicólogos nos llamaron y
nos dijeron el diagnóstico su hija tiene
tdh cuando nos dijeron eso yo pensé y
que es el cdh yo escuchado pero la
verdad no tenía ni idea le preguntamos a
la psiquiatra en qué consistía y que
afectaba y sus respuestas siempre fueron
directas y sinceras es un trastorno
neurológico y afecta al cerebro no tiene
cura se puede tratar por medio de
medicamentos y terapias de psiquiatría y
psicólogo su hija maría del mar piensa
diferente
entiende diferente de sus tiempos son
diferentes y para hablar lo más sencillo
es que las vías que conectan los
circuitos del cerebro deben ser avenidas
pavimentadas
esas vías en el cerebro de mariana mar
son truchas haciendo que las
instrucciones sean difíciles de asimilar
inmediatamente posterior
en las mujeres llegará el diagnóstico es
más difícil porque normalmente no son
malas estudiantes ni en juicios que son
los síntomas más visibles de este
trastorno esas fueron las palabras
sencillas y claras de la psiquiatra para
la respuesta a un millón de preguntas
que teníamos en el sector
claramente quedamos peor sin imaginar en
el mundo en el que sin escoger ya
estábamos ahí íbamos a quedarnos para
siempre
maria del mar una línea brillante buena
estudiante siempre sacando medalla
excelente desempeño académico deportista
con una personalidad encantadora campeón
en su carácter siendo selección valle y
selección colombia yo no podía creer lo
que estaba escuchando
en ese instante pensaba todo lo que me
había cuestionado sobre mi papel como
mamá creyendo que la tarea me había
quedado durante de hecho llegué a pensar
como le digo a la gente que mi hija
tiene esos comportamientos porque tiene
un trastorno neurológico y evitar así un
rechazo social ya que este tipo de
trastorno en nuestra sociedad no son
bien vistos porque no han sido visibles
para ser comprendidos
el ph es un trastorno mental que para el
ts entre un 2 y un 5 por ciento de la
población infantil en el mundo los
expertos dicen que la causa del cdh se
debe a factores principalmente genéticos
y ambientales y los principales síntomas
son hiperactividad varias manos se queda
quieta un minuto déficit de atención
todo lo deja para el último momento y su
desorden es continuo y la imposibilidad
de agresividad que se dan por las
comorbilidades como el trastorno de
oposición desafiante todo que empeora el
diagnóstico y la hace más agresiva más
impulsiva el más retador está
comorbilidad también la tiene mariana
como muchas enfermedades invisibles no
tiene cura con el tratamiento de
profesionales especializados se podrá
controlar y aprender con el tiempo a
nivelar impulsos lo único claro es que
es un aprendizaje continuo para todos en
casa inclusive para mí martina de cuatro
años a la que le tuve que explicarle que
la hermanita tenía un bichito en la
cabeza y que cuando la picaba hacía que
se comportará así
ahora entiendo por qué maría del mar
tenía muchos comportamientos
particulares
a sus 4 años no le gustaba lavarse los
dientes siempre fue muy complejo lloraba
gritaba y hasta los vecinos pensaban que
algo le estaba haciendo y pensaba que
complejo es cuidarle la otra persona en
el colegio por ejemplo era sido a
visitante de la enfermería iba con
alguna excusa simplemente porque se
aburría en las clases
pero lo más duro pues saber que es una
fiesta infantil los adultos empezaron a
hablar mal de maría
que para la época tenía más o menos
cinco añitos expresando que era una niña
mandona irritante grosera y conflictiva
desconociendo algo que yo también
desconocía de ahí en adelante nunca más
la volverán a invitar a ninguna fiesta y
en ninguna actividad por el colegio y es
una esencia me decía mamá todos fueron
que a mí no me invitaron y yo siempre le
respondía no te preocupes y habrán
muchas fiestas más y lo peor fue que ese
aislamiento también fue aplicado para
nosotros como padres y pasamos solamente
a ser saludados en los momentos de la
entrega de notas de maría del mal
con el pasar del tiempo maría el mar a
empezó a manifestar quererse cambiar del
colegio ya que se sentía sola al punto
que en un episodio muy fuerte pasó a ser
lanza para porque su papá delató a un
compañerito que estaba compartiendo
contenido inapropiado para su edad y
esto complicó más la situación tanto así
que maría del mar al no sabe sola en el
mar
de verdad que sufrió y yo como mamá
sufría el doble porque no podía decirle
a todos los compañeros lo que se me
ocurría no podía defender a mi hija yo
soy el adulto y decirles algo o hacerle
ese reclamo era exponerla más y lo peor
de todo era tener problemas con otros
padres el colegio nos hizo un
acompañamiento pero ya mi hija había
sufrido lo suficiente y no solo por el
capítulo de google sino por todos los
años que llevaba pidiendo que la
cambiaremos de colegio
en muchas conversaciones con mi esposo
llegamos a una conclusión y decidimos
que lo mejor era que maría del mar
hiciera un proceso en otro colegio y que
esperábamos saber qué pasaba que el
tiempo podría ayudar porque el tiempo lo
cura todo
y mientras pasaba ese tiempo que se
supone que nos iba a ayudar pasaron
muchas cosas y siempre me excusé que
había llegado la preadolescencia y que
el bullying había marcado mucho por eso
empezó a tener acompañamiento del
psicólogo era perfecto la iba a ayudar a
superar el bullying y además alivianar
las cosas de la preadolescencia pero
cada vez era peor
hasta cuando llegó la pandemia y con
ella la cuarentena
he tenido que leer y aprender mucho
sobre el trastorno y encontré que muchas
de las personas que admiramos y que
consideramos brillantes son th por
ejemplo will smith
steve jobs michael phelps y bill gates
entre muchos más no ha sido fácil para
la familia comprender esta situación
pero si nos hemos visto expuestos a la
mirada de muchas personas por los
comportamientos de maría del mal alguno
en algunos momentos hasta que no
escuchan nuestra versión o nuestra
situación la consideraban hasta mala
influencia
como sociedad debemos empezar a entender
que hay niños que se comportan de manera
diferente y que es probable que sean
niños neuro diversos como memoria de
hermanos
que todo el tiempo fue mal etiquetada
por no conocer su condición por esto hoy
vengo a decirles que el mundo necesita
comprender a estos niños e integrarlos y
dejar de juzgarlos solamente porque sus
necesidades son diferentes estos niños
son como cualquier otro les gusta jugar
reír son cariñosos y aprenden mucho de
las actitudes de los padres y de sus
comentarios
la sociedad de generar unos cambios que
permitan potencializar las cualidades y
habilidades de estos niños y así
disminuir la brecha de inclusión en la
sociedad con las enfermedades invisibles
para lograr hacer visible lo invisible
muchas gracias